now while Americans are not afraid to
stand up and say what they really think
about this indictment many of the
establishment gopiers are just staying
oddly silent
they think that by doing that and
letting Biden do whatever he wants for
the executive branch that they're
protecting the national security
agencies
but they are not they're simply allowing
those agencies to become more and more
discredited in the eyes of the public
every Republican senator who wants to
have a strong FBI should be furious with
what the Biden Administration is doing
because its actions are weakening a
vital U.S institution and thus they're
endangering the United States
one Senator is giving it right back to
the Democrats Ohio's JD Vance today
threatened to block all of Biden's
judicial nominees until Merrick Garland
stops using his agencies to harass Joe
Biden's political opponents Senator
Vance joins me now
um Senator any other your colleagues
going to join your effort you know I
think a few of my colleagues will a few
of my colleagues are already pretty
actively pushing back against Joe
Biden's department of justice but here's
the crazy thing here is we actually have
some Authority and we can use it to do
something good for the American people
what so many senators I think are
terrified of doing is giving is using
the Constitutional Authority the
American people have given us the the
the political appointees the Department
of Justice the way to look at them is
foot soldiers for turning the doj into
Political activism instead of actively
doing the job of enforcing the law why
should we be giving Joe Biden more foot
soldiers when he's using them to attack
his political opponents and
conservatives all across the country
it's insane no CNN not surprisingly went
after your announcement today watch this
there's a supporter just doubling down
we are seeing not just from Donald Trump
Republican Senators undermining the
justice department and rule of law
so it's not the fact that they are
applying Justice unequally It's You by
actually using your constitutionally
authorized uh you know position to say
no no you have to give us information or
we're not going to comply that's exactly
right I'm undermining the rule of law by
doing the job of a United States Senator
it's totally insane I think one of these
people actually accused me of
obstructing justice myself uh by by
actually going afterwards the
politically motivated appointees here
but the Lord this is insane here it's
the president's constitutional
prerogative to declassify or classify
whatever documents he wishes the idea
that Joe Biden and Hillary Clinton
before Joe Biden never became president
get to mishandle classified information
face no consequences and Joe Biden uh
gets away scot-free and Donald Trump is
going to be put in prison for the rest
of his life that's what they're trying
to do for declassifying documents as he
has the Constitutional Authority do it's
crazy and we cannot continue to give the
Department of Justice free reign just
set themselves loose on the American
people unlimited funding unlimited
resources and unlimited Personnel we can
as a U.S Senate effectively grind the
appointments process and Merrick
Garland's Department of Justice to a
halt why don't we do it the American
people I think expected of it do you
think your colleagues and Leadership who
are more establishment types do they
understand that 81 percent of
Republicans think this indictment is
politically motivated are they aware of
where the political winds have shifted
in the GOP are they just going like it's
you know you know 2004 all over again I
think they're aware of it Laura but
they're so caught up in the DC media
environment that they they don't
remember the implications of this if we
sort of step back and think of the Trump
presidency every single alleged Scandal
there was this initial Rush of news and
then it turned out when you look at the
details it wasn't nearly as bad as the
DC press Corps would lead us to believe
I think they need to remember here that
all of the sensationalism around this
indictment we're going to learn the
truth and I suspect the truth is not
going to be nearly as bad as it's
reported on CNN the day after the
indictment what's happened to the
Public's trust in institutions is I
think far more significant than a bunch
of documents being kept sloppily in a
bathroom
we now have the American people at least
half the country believing they can't
trust the FBI the justice department
how significant is that and again do
your Republican colleagues realize what
this indictment is going to do to that
it's hugely significant and this is the
argument I make look I'm obviously I've
endorsed Donald Trump but I would make
this argument to people who are not
going to support Donald Trump this is
really not about who was president it's
about the office of the presidency
itself do you use that office to harass
your political opponents or do you use
that office to enforce the law what
we're seeing here is such selective
enforcement you're absolutely right it's
going to destroy the people's faith in
equal administration of the law if you
have democrats facing one set of
principles and Republicans facing the
harshest application of the law then
you're going to eliminate people's faith
that the law is about what you do and
whether you do it the right way
who's going to sign up that's exactly
right why are you going to sign up for a
military that is applying Justice
unequally why are you going to send your
kids to to law school why are you going
to pay pay your taxes the entire
Foundation of this country is that
whether you're a democrat or a
republican we all face the same justice
system Joe Biden's Department of Justice
is going to war against that principle
they're going to break the country
unless we stop it JD Vance great to see
you as always thanks for coming in
tonight hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else